I've made films with people and I said
look I don't care what really happened
I'm making a movie here and I always say
why I get that can we find out what it
really happened then and see if that is
we can make that manifest on the stage
as opposed to just making up something
whole cloth even in some fictional
movies that take place with with a true
procedure or actual history behind it
that's where I automatically go to is
let's find out what actually happened
and and Paul gave sort of a tacit carte
blanche to go figure out everything go
find out everything you can and on the
day of course we'll try to incorporate
as much empirical truth as we can
so based on that the first thing I said
to Richard Phillips when I met him was
I'm going to say things you never said
I'm going to do things you never did but
that's just the nature of the
compression that must happen in order to
get the story beyond that comes a
version of the of the truth that you
must shoot for we all know the confines
of how hard it is to make a good movie
period but if my job as the actor is to
go out and load up myself things that
are said or unset of the real
circumstance the real man the real
procedure the real behavior well then I
have I have like almost and I have a
greatly annotated screenplay that I get
to work with because I find I for
particularly for rich Phillips I just
found out the incredibly complicated I
call it an algorithm that was goes on in
his head just to run a ship period much
less the new trigonometry that has to
enter into it when two skiffs appear on
the horizon and those guys have guns
then this whole other thing has to begin
and look it's not necessarily anything
that has come out that is stated but it
ends up being imprinted somehow in in in
key moments of the behavior throughout
and that is a wonderful thing to be able
to have in your
this gentleman here on my left we knew
each other a little bit but I'd always
wanted to make a film with Tom and it
was my one chance I see both hands
that's to be honest was the biggest part
also there was a personal thing my
father was in the Merchant Marine in the
40s and 50s and spent his life at sea he
later became a PI up you know an ocean
pilot so I felt I knew something about
that world or rather I didn't know
anything about that world and wanted to
know you know that thing we you don't
really understand your father's life
because it's lived away from you you
know but their particular sorts of
people you know people go to sea it's a
calling you know it's in something deep
inside them and they tend to be men of
few words they certainly don't cry
they're hard-working men you know so on
Wednesday I'm going to show him the film
he's very elderly now but he's going to
come down we'll somehow manage to figure
out how to get him into the theater and
I can guarantee you as anybody here has
grown up in a in a in a and a household
you know where the father goes to see he
will find every single thing the trumpet
happy but first right last and he will
tell me all well I know that you worked
with a casting director on this film
Francine remake seriously one of the
things you find when you direct films is
you're given credit for all sorts of
things that really truly belong
elsewhere that was an absolute case in
point I I said to Francine so we're
going to need to find Somali actors and
the pretty sure there isn't a Somali
acting community in Los Angeles or New
York so what are we going to do Francie
and she went great I love challenges
like so she and her team I went to work
they went to Minneapolis
and and I put out an advert on the
television I'll let Barker tell you what
happened so I'm just hanging out at my
friend's house and how are you doing at
your friend's house I purchase how it
begins for us all yeah at her friend's
house and then he came on the TV Tom
Hanks casting call Somali actress that's
all I needed to hear I went there the
next day and it's a big crowd of people
like almost close to 800,000 hundred and
they asked me a very simple questions
what's your name were you born and how
old are you after that I was given a
piece of paper then I had a part of the
script and I was assigned to the
character Moosa stole to come back the
next day one writes the lines the second
day I come back less crowd of people now
but then I was told to that I cannot
audition by myself that I need to be
part of a group there's a lot of guys
there but then we had to either form our
own group or wait and until we became
part of a group and there I was with a
group of my friends Nels there three of
my friends that you know we live in the
same buildings for a long time so so we
form our own group and we didn't do that
good the first day and after night we
went home when we practice and we came
back the second day and we did better
we edition few times and then we
Francine give us a call to LA there we
need Paul Greengrass all four of them
were really good and I had great group
identity you know and I had great
individual definition one from another
they they'd understood in stinking it
because they're good actors you know
that's it
we saw the terror in your eyes and we
saw
terror in in mooses eyes but once seen
in particularly I struck out for me as
that scene where moose has holding the
gun to captain Phillips head and when he
removes it there's the gun imprint on
your forehead take us to that day out
ouch yeah well I'll go first but you got
to take some of this man because we we
were it was an incredibly small
foul-smelling place even though it was
fake we were on the gimbal on the set
but we were all pumped you know in the
in the best way I mean we had brakes and
we'd laugh and moose barkhad Barca ma
and face all would speak in their
language that I didn't understand and
I'd say what what what and they're
arguing about something who knows what
went on but but then we would get back
into it and we were it's it's it's
environmental more than anything else it
starts and it almost always went on for
a very long time it was we never did I
don't think we ever did scenes that
lasted you know 40 seconds or 30 seconds
they were all six seven sometimes
sometimes 12 minute scenes and you what
can you say you just go there and you
don't you don't really sensing anything
but the fact that the your vote emotion
is at a fever pitch right Vockrodt why
don't you tell us a little bit about
that undone your end of it your side of
it yeah it was um because you're working
with Tom Hanks right that senior pushing
guns in his head well I took the gun
pride make me feel like it is all him
I'm not Olivia to heaven for crying out
loud there you know jeez yeah but that
scene was really hard you know I
understood the weight of it and just I
remember thinking about it a lot that
night and I didn't know what to do
honestly til the next day I came and
told just told me just take control and
you know just do it you know this is
your time you have to take care of this
scene
that's when I just used a lot of
imaginations and just became the
character as much as I can and I became
the captain yes you did I did yes you
did
so how where do where do we also became
an actor cos right after he done that
same there was a big argument before
guys went offered to go was a huge
argument I went over and I said what's
the argument about a bucket said it's
Phi so he keeps getting in my shop oh
boy he's well away